Comtrya.
Welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. I will
explain that Comtrya reference very,
very soon.
But I wanna welcome you back. Happy New
Year, and this is the first stream of
and a very special one for me because
we're taking a look at a project I've
been involved with for a long time now,
and I get to be joined by someone
I call a friend.
Hey,
Todd, man. How's it going? Not too bad.
Yourself?
Yeah. All the better now. You know, at
the end of the day, I get to
end in a fun way, which is, you
know, with some pretty cool dev tools written
in Rust. We might as well throw that
out there pretty early.
But before we talk more about Comtrya and
what we're gonna show today, do you wanna
just give a a little bit of an
introduction to the audience at home?
Alright. Once again, Todd Martin. I'm one of
the maintainers, I guess, now probably the primary
maintainer
since I've kinda got the free time to
look after it.
Software engineer during my day job. I slinged
C Sharp for a smaller company and then
do Comtrya during my free time. I first
came to it because of another
friend, Michael Ream,
out of Germany who actually pointed me to
Comtrya for a project we were looking at
for VSD and then ended up becoming a
contributor and then later on a maintainer.
Alright.
Even if there's a very annoying buzzing sound,
I've turned off a space heater because it's
pretty cold here. And if that doesn't fix
it, I will pop a cable and put
it back in, which is the universal answer
to all audio issues. Mhmm. So let me
know in thirty seconds if that goes away.
Alright. Thank you for the quick introduction.
Why don't you tell us
what Comtrya
is, what it does, and what you were
potentially looking to use it for?
So,
originally,
I believe you started it as a dot
file manager tool and kind of the primary
purpose, and it's kind of grown in scope
since then to kind of include a lot
more
system management general system management and configuration
outside of just specifically managing dot files.
The future of it for me,
as I see it going, is leaning more
into the the system configuration and management portion,
and that's actually what I use it for.
I've been using it a lot at work,
the stand up systems,
and have a configuration
and ease deployment.
Thanks.
Yeah. I mean, that's
I don't know the blessing or the curse
of all projects. Eventually, scope creep happens, and
it does more and more.
So, yeah, we could talk about how the
project is growing. But maybe you could take
what you said and condense it into, like,
a thirty second pitch for someone who's never
used Comtrya before. Why should they install it,
and what is that kind of default use
case? What would they use it for? Oh,
that's a good one. I never really thought
about, like, a thirty second pitch.
I mean, I put you on the spot
while
I was, you know, fixing that cable, but
apparently, I'm back.
Yeah.
I would say,
if I had to quickly get one off
the top of my head without thinking too
deeply into it, say, dot file system configuration
management tool written in Rust with hopefully bringing
some of the safety that Rust brings, with
pooling,
really.
Yeah. I'm I'm gonna pay it on to
that just because, obviously, I am very familiar
with Comtrya. To anyone who doesn't know, I
bootstrapped the project
four, five years ago now. I think it
was '20 late twenty nineteen.
Maybe it was 2020. I should twice. I
don't even know.
But my I was trying to scratch my
own itch. I
am a serial OS wiper.
Like, I like to format my machines pretty
much religiously every 30. Religiously might not be
the right word. But with thirty day cadence
because
promotes
better
habits with my machine. I don't like clutter.
I like a fresh system. I
don't wanna lose anything really this older than
thirty days. It makes sure that I back
stuff up where I need to back it
up. And, also, it's just fun to distro
hop. You know, I'm a Linux user. So,
you know, whether I'm running XSOS today, I
might be Arch tomorrow. Next week, I might
be in Silverblue again. Like,
I'm just insatiable when it comes to Linux,
and I'm always jumping about and experimenting and
kicking tires on things. And Comtrya is the
reason I started a project was to, okay,
how do I get from, oh, shit, here's
the fresh machine to how do I get
back to work without wasting an entire day?
Because let's be honest, right, you get a
new machine
so at least two days of just messing
about installing stuff and testing out new extensions.
I I don't know. Maybe I'm just terrible
procrastinator.
I I can't stop installing software, and Comtrya
was trying to alleviate the burden of some
of that at least anyway. Mhmm.
Okay. So how long have you been
you know, you are the the primary and
I think almost sole maintainer. There's a few
external contributors that are obviously submitting patches and
and using the project, but, know, you've been
working on this. I'm I I I don't
even know. Like, a year now? Has it
been that long? Has it been less? I'm
not sure. Yeah. I think it was about
this time last year where you had brought
up that you were getting busy with
you going out and starting your own thing
and meeting one of us to kinda meet
or Stephan, who's also in chat, kinda picking
up some of the
some more of the deeper maintainership duties.
Actually, I think it was a little bit
before that that you
added me to the crates so that way
I can start doing releases. Yeah.
Last year where
I think you had mentioned that you were
getting a little busy, and you need one
of us to kinda take it up more.
And then it came up over the summer,
and I kinda took it the rest of
the way.
Yeah. And I think you've shipped quite a
lot in that time. You know? And don't
worry to the people watching going, just get
just show me a terminal already. Right? We're
gonna get hands on very, very soon. But,
you know, for me personally,
having not having not oh, that's a terrible
thing. Not having the time
to work on a project like Comtrya was
really disappointing to me because
it solves an itch. It's a space that
I like.
But just seeing you deliver new features month
after month over the last year It's really
kinda like
it's it's I could smell on the face.
I'd be so happy to see the project
moving on and changing. You know, the TOML
support, I think, was fantastic, and there's a
whole bunch of other features, like, you know,
supporting
run zero as a privilege elevator.
It's just so cool to see all these
things coming together. I've seen more activity on
the GitHub across issues and pull requests.
You know, that little bit of momentum that
you pushed into the project is now paying
compound dividends as far as I'm concerned. I'm
seeing
more adoption, more interest, and more engagement. So
I I I could not be happier with
the position of Comtrya today, and I'm excited
for us to share that screen, get a
terminal open, and actually show people how they
can get started and
hopefully make their lives a little bit easier.
Yeah. But before,
you know, you were an early adopter of
Comtrya too. I mean, we're going back years
now. Right? Yeah. And one of the things
that I think drew use of the project
and is still very prominent today is that
we always say Comtrya should be able to
run anywhere. So maybe you can give a
little bit of flavor and color on why
that's a goal and the kind of platforms
that we support.
Yeah. So guess start off with the platforms
we support.
Windows, Mac OS,
Linux.
There's a little bit of an asterisk to
that. The only reason I would say that
there's an asterisk to that is because of
providers, and it's like, there's hundreds of distros.
If you look for well, as
viewers will see later, there's, like, a package
installed so that way Comtrya can install packages.
We don't have every distro in there, but
if we can add it, I'm more than
happy to. I just need to know what
the distro is so that way I can
add it. But it's also impossible to add
every possible distro in existence there. But for
the most part, we can support any Linux.
And then
BSD,
but not all BSDs right now. The main
ones are free BSD and net BSD.
I think in theory, most everything should work
except for maybe the package install on Dragonfly
BSD, and that's just because free BSD and
Dragonfly BSD,
while they are two distinct projects, still share
a lot of a lot of
similarity.
OpenBSD
has kinda been the painful redheaded stepchild, unfortunately.
Like, it's a platform I would love to
support, but there are some hurdles that have
to be overcome and not just by me
to fully
confidently support OpenBSD.
We technically could today.
The reason I don't is because and why
I don't do anything specifically
is because the Rust tool chain tends to
fall behind often in OpenBSD.
Last time I looked, there's one poor soul
who's maintaining that for OpenBSD,
and, it's
kinda like a constant game of catch up
for them.
Yeah.
I mean, I think there's still
pretty wide support right off the bat. And
and the Linux thing is obviously tricky because
you don't wanna
have to write Rust code to support a
new package manager. And then maybe this is
something we could talk about at the end,
but, you know, just thinking about that for
all four seconds there. Like, there's no reason
Comtrya.YAML
is a config fail. It couldn't support specifying
custom installers because all you need is a
command with some arguments for each of the
different verbs. So
maybe we're maybe it just gonna turn into
let's let's fail a pull request and that's
some cool functionality. But
Yeah. Yeah. We could we could we could
make that easier for people that wanna experiment
with different test tools that don't have hard
coded support. Definitely.
And I guess one thing to add with
platform support, that's probably one of the more
difficult aspects of the project. I do get
people who hit me up on Discord and
issues where they're like, hey. I wanna do
this really cool thing. And then the battle
is always,
how can I implement a feature that doesn't
either
break something on another operating system or
cause massive issues? Really, the biggest one here
being Windows because, you know, a
lot of things, especially since we do kinda
shell out, work roughly the same between macOS,
BSD, and Linux. Windows is kind of the
different one here where it's not everything is
one to one. For instance, like, a privilege
escalation works totally different on the Unix c
platforms. We can just sudo
DoS run zero, but Windows
apparently, we'll have sudo at some point. Last
I heard that they're implementing their own sudo
and Windows preview at some point, so maybe
that'll line up. But
as far as I know, for most Windows
systems, they don't have something that's equivalent.
Hell, I mean, if they roll out schedule
support, you're looking at a future
where you could run a Comtrya apply
and not only provision the Windows host, but
multiple WSL
virtual machines at the same time with one
set of manifests.
And, you know, the variant support and manifests
as we're gonna get to soon, I I
think is one of the superpowers of Comtrya
and one that I've definitely very poorly documented
early doors, and it's getting better, but I
don't even think we've tapped into
what that enables enough.
I think there's more to be done there.
However,
we have been talking now for the best
part of fifteen minutes, and we haven't shown
any code. And we've only said Rust once
or twice. So Yeah. Maybe we should
Before
we
jump in, do we wanna just kinda show
up the documentation?
Yeah. We should. Yeah. Definitely.
K. Alright.
Let me pull up the screen share.
Alright. Your screen is up. We see the
Comtrya man. Oh, we haven't spoke about the
name.
So it's a it's a total Stargate SG
one reference. Right? Like, I don't know if
everybody has seen this episode, but it's one
of my favorites. And I believe this man
is called Hanlon. Yeah. Hanlon. And he says
Comtrya, which is like their their greeting and
their welcome. So
yeah. Always makes me smile to see his
face in the bee mooch.
And it also gives the project a nice
name, I think, little bit unique too.
Don't think you said too. You Google it,
and all you find is Stargate or
or a little Rust project. So Yeah.
Kinda wanna show the documentation first just in
case anybody wanna follow along. And
as David had said, improvements to the documentation.
This has been rather recent in the last
year is moving it over to using MDBook,
so adding more Rust
tool chain in there. So there's another Rust
reference for you.
There's still some areas where it lacks, and
I'm hoping to correct that over time. But
as you can see, it's pretty easy to
navigate.
Got our introduction, a little rundown. I think
most of this is from the older documentation
which you had on Gitbook.
We got our supported systems,
how we're gonna install it, or the different
ways to install it,
a little bit about CLI,
the different commands that CLI has to offer,
but the real meat of this documentation is
here underneath the manifest and the actions.
Nice.
Yeah. I like this format much better than
the the GetBook stuff. I mean, the GetBook
was great, and, you know, they support open
source by providing their platform for free. But
I think the entire deployment pipeline you put
together for this is is flick and quite
quite nice to navigate. Yeah.
That's that's kinda why I like going with
this option. So now the documentation is kept
in repo alongside the code.
I guess one complaint you could have is
that every single time a pull request happens,
even if the documentation doesn't change, technically, they
get pipeline publishes a new version of the
documentation.
Okay. Maybe it's a little publishing when it
doesn't need to. But the
bottom line is it's, if somebody were to
do a feature, they could have the code
for the feature and the code for the
documentation all in the same pull request. And
once it gets pulled in, it's spam. It's
on the main branch of Comtrya, and the
documentation is live immediately.
Yeah. I think that one or repo approach.
I mean, it's the secret sauce for these
projects because the problem we had with my
setup was people were sending really awesome pull
requests, but the documentation was a different repository.
It never got updated out of this month,
if not longer behind.
Mhmm. Yeah. This is cool. I like this.
So Stefan
is already in the chat,
sticking me on it. So
Stefan is correct. There there was an example
written
by me, unfortunately,
that every time you ran the tests or
you ran against the examples directory, it would
reboot your machine.
And we thought this was a bug until
we looked in the examples and realized that
dumbass here had a special command run system
control reboot at a
Yeah. Underneath I've never done that again.
Yeah. So so I guess some background. So
it it was me coming into the Discord
chat kinda like, guys, guys, I think we
have a major problem.
And I'm sitting here, and I'm like, okay.
Because I didn't look at all the examples.
I'm just running them and testing them for
whatever I was doing at the time. And
then I started going like, okay. I'm gonna
need to debug the kernel on this.
So I'm sitting here doing all this, and
then, yes, Stefan comes up, and he's like,
it's probably because of one of our examples.
We have a where clause where if you're
on Linux, we just reboot the machine.
Not not the my famous moment, but oh,
well.
Clearly, I've just been like, okay. What could
a a good work clause be that's Linux
specific? And I've just been, oh, yeah. System
deep. And
yeah. One idea.
Yeah. For, for anyone,
I guess a little bit of information about
that word clause and to give some information
about it. Here in the Comtrya documentation, you
see an example of it where we can
have variants of a command. So we can
kinda change the behavior of a certain action
depending on, like, the operating system. And I
think there's some other parameters, but probably the
one that I've seen most commonly in other
people's manifest is like, oh, if on Linux,
do this. If on Oh, the repo is
still there.
In the example, but I believe I did
actually it's just a copy and paste.
Let's
see.
Go back.
Because I'm pretty sure I changed that out.
I hope I did. Yeah. It was in
here.
I think I just changed it to a
no? It's under variance, I think. Only variance.
Only variance.
Yeah. And I changed it just to do
an echo.
Just like the other ones. For some reason,
we had echo for
Mac OS. But Yeah. Last came out two
years ago.
Not because I I can't even believe it
was that long ago, but there you go.
Yeah. There it is. Changed the example for
Linux so not to cause the system reboot.
Yeah. Shit happens.
No kidding.
Alright. Should we focus on the installation process
first? How can people get Comtrya on the
command line?
Alright. So we will actually pop back up
to
this. I already have it installed in my
VM, but
and I did it through the
curl way. So we have a couple of
different ways. One, you could get the Rust
tool chain, and you can cargo install it
because it is on Crates.io,
and you can get it that way. And
that'll also give you the main branch.
We do have a shell script,
hosted at git.comtrya.dev
that you can just pipe in the shell.
With it, you can also pin a version
number, so can give an exact version number
if you need an older version.
We also have the precompiled binaries underneath our
releases section on GitHub. You can pull it
from there.
And then we do have it available in
some package managers.
Stefan has been kind enough
to package it for the AUR on Arch
for a long time.
Michael Green, the guy I mentioned earlier who
initially introduced me to Comtrya packages it for
RavenPorch, which is a smaller
porch tree kinda style package management system that's
supposed to be cross platform.
And then
here recently over the last few months, I
added it to Homebrew.
Nice.
Yeah. I think that Homebrew approach for Mac
people just makes it very, very simple.
Alright. Shall we write our first manifest?
Sure. May I just make a
directory and call it configuration?
Because there's reason you chose Debian, or is
that just because you feel that, you know,
Tammy, you're back with us at this point?
Debian
has always kinda been I kinda consider my
home distro. Like, I distro hopped a lot,
but Debian is kinda always where I return
especially as an adult because things are just
nice and stable there and,
rock solid. Know what's stable?
I'm a bleeding edge. Yeah.
It's also what I've been, using at work
whenever I deploy servers. Well, at first, I
tried Ubuntu, and then I realized why I
don't deploy servers on Ubuntu.
And
then
so then I just went with Debian,
and that's where I've mostly been using Comtrya
is on Debian servers at work right now.
Nice.
Alright.
So
what kind of saw? What kind of man
Why don't we start
with just basic you know,
I'm trying not to come out with too
much bias because I know what Comtrya can
do. But let's start with a command execution.
Let's assume people just wanted, like, a YAML
interface to some sort of bash script, which
I would never encourage anyone to do. But
command execution is
probably one of the quicker and easiest ways
to start doing stuff with Comtrya.
Yeah.
Just,
like, oh.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. I always forget that
even after, what, fifteen years of using Linux.
Let's call it main.
Alright. So
So this is what we call a manifest.
Right? Yep. This is a a manifest,
a YAML file, or it can be a
TOML file.
And then just kinda follow the example here.
So every manifest
the basic manifest are is essentially just a
collection of actions.
So we prefix it at the top with
actions, and then we define each action within
that.
So we'll just start off with a simple
command dot run
and make sure I have the documentation up.
Because I usually always make sure I have
it up so I don't mess something up.
Just do a simple echo.
Do that part.
Perfect.
Alright.
And as
David said, I mean, to me, I kinda
consider the command dot run as, a catch
all. If there's anything that Comtrya doesn't have
an action that it directly supports, there's usually
always a way to get it done with
the with the command dot run-in some fashion.
Yeah. It's especially with the variance syntax. Like,
if you need to run something differently across
Linux, BSD, Mac, Windows, whatever, it's easiest to
do that as a single action
rather than, you know, the thing I really
hated and tried to avoid as much as
possible was crazy ginger templating within, say, Jamo
because I think things just get messy and
hacky pretty quick.
Mhmm.
But, of course, you can do change of
template, but
there's always the escape patch.
Yep.
Alright. So down here, I'm gonna run it,
essentially, just invoking the I can try a
binary. The dash d flag gives it the
directories. We're just saying the current working directory
wherein is
essentially the root for our manifest and then
apply.
And then Comtrya also allows the ability to
you don't have to run all your manifests.
You can selectively run them by giving this
m switch.
Yeah. Oh, did not get any output there.
You need to add dash v. Oh, yeah.
More v's.
Yeah. No? Nope.
I don't think it's running.
Oh, yeah. I might wanna make sure.
Oh, I thought I checked this checked this
yesterday.
Uh-oh.
Yep.
If not, I guess I could do this
on my Mac too.
But what happens if you type type Comtrya?
What does it think it is or which
Comtrya? Do we have do we have anything?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. It does. And let's I mean,
run type space before
we cat it just to be sure it's
a text file.
Try as hashed.
Vimit?
No.
Yeah. Well, I primarily use Emacs,
but Woah. Woah. Nano is just available. Oh,
yeah. There we go. Yeah. That that's a
problem.
Yeah. That is a problem. Now we get
to show the installation.
Yeah.
Well, you quickly grab that command. I'll say
happy New Year to Nuno as well. Hey.
Nice to see you again.
Let's see. It may we may have an
issue with the installation script,
At least on ARM,
I will say this is Is that an
ARM's what happens if you type your name
dash a? Is it AMD with
or ARM?
It's dash a.
It's ARM 64. Four. Yeah. So it should
I create
Pop this over so I can read it
and type at the same time.
Version.
And you've put dev instead of dev. Oh,
yeah.
That's because you're debbing mad.
Pipe it through bash.
That's that's the bash test condition.
Alright.
Maybe there's a docs error there. Yeah. There
we go.
And it grabbed the ARM 64 version. So,
I mean, that works fine. It's just the
sweet. There we go. There
we go. Alright.
Yeah. I'm also hoping we don't have any
issues with,
what was it, ganulib c
that has been a rather recent issue that,
at least on
AMD sixty four, has kinda gotten solved.
There we go.
It's running Alright. Let's Comtrya. I'll see you
all later. I'm going home.
Do you wanna pump a dash v onto
that just so we can see the actual
echo statement as well? So Comtrya tries to
hide
output, but it doesn't need to show you
it.
But you can enable
deeper verbosity
as you can see there.
Yep. So as we can see, we have
a to standard out, we have hello just
as defined in our manifest.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's push our luck. Let's install
NeoVim.
Alright.
Let's just
I I I just pecked NeoVim because you
said you like Emacs, and I feel like
I have to make you do the devil's
work.
Let's keep it here.
Action
package dot install
and
make sure it's the only thing about YAML.
It's a lot of times also mess up
the spacing.
What?
What's the package name?
NeoVent.
Oh, double check that
because I never installed it. Just NeoVent.
Alright.
Can
you just run
Uh-oh.
Yeah. It's your indentation.
Oh, yeah.
Can you try and run nVim just so
we know it's not on the machine first
as well?
Yeah.
So your second action needs to be one
space less.
I think that's
three in.
No. Up two lanes?
I think there's three spaces at the start.
Right?
I believe so. One, two, three. Or is
it two? There's two, but two lanes up.
The package install lane, I think, is three
spaces
at the start.
Three spaces.
Yeah. At the start of that lane. Oh,
here? Yeah. We'll go back one. Yeah. There
we go. Okay. And then fix list and
then fix the yeah.
Yeah. No YAML mode here to help me.
But your NeoVem is still one, two, two
Oh, yeah.
If you were just in Venn, this wouldn't
be an issue.
Or Emacs because I we just have YAML
mode.
Sweet.
Yep. And that'll take a minute. I do
kinda wanna
eventually solve that. This seems to always be
the first time it runs on Debian. It
always does that where it complains about the
the ad repository. It's like, well, we're not
mean to do anything with ad in a
repository.
So something I eventually wanna dig down into.
But
Yeah. I was curious about that too, but
we do have NeoVim, so that's a pretty
solid start.
Clear that out.
See what should we play around with.
Well, I think we've got two
opt I mean, we can go into whatever
you want, but,
you know, right now, we have a single
manifest. Can you list the commands directory? What
did you put in there?
Oh, what did I put in there?
Just main dot YAML and Yeah. You know,
main dot YAML is a special name in
Comtrya. It just means you can reference that
manifest by the parent directory, which is commands
in this case. So why don't we
move the NeoVim package installed to its own
manifest and then show us some sort of
dependency management as well?
Will do. So
let's see. Directory.
Because one of the really cool things about
Comtrya is that under the hood, it's processing
and parsing all of this YAML or TOML
and and building a
directed graph.
So you can actually have
whatever dependency structure you need across multiple manifests,
and it handles it
really well.
Is typing YAML why you added TOML support?
No.
Somebody had asked for it. I'm
kinda like you. I'm not too big of
a fan of
TOML, but it was kinda easy enough, and
somebody had asked for it. And I was
like, oh, that's that's also what at at
the time, it was something different
for me to do. Like, I think at
that point, most everything I had done was
just in the actions themselves.
And I haven't really messed with anything as
far as, like, how we walk through the
manifest or any of the other parts of
Comtrya. I was kind of just in the
actions.
Hadn't messed with Adams yet, really.
So I was like, well, this will get
me into a different part of it, and
I can kinda look at it. And
because Surday makes it so easy to support
multiple different file formats, I was like, it's
not gonna be hard. Get me into a
part that I'm not used to.
So
That NVM should be NeoVim before you save
it.
Alright.
Saved.
Okay. So now we've got is that software
main and commands main?
Yep. Or Okay. I did it as
as in Okay.
I can change that if we want. No.
No. No. I think that that that works
just fine. So why don't we update commands
to depend on software?
Remember, if you're watching and you have any
questions and or you want some examples about
some of the things Comtrya can do, now
would be a good time to throw them
into the chat so that we can,
you know, hopefully show you something interesting.
And dependencies.
Oh, I haven't had to do too much
with the dependencies yet.
Would it be Software.envim.
Yeah. I mean, I could talk because I
wrote this code, I could talk about how
this works and where the inspiration came from
as well. Because some people may hate the
syntax, but it's actually something I stole from
SaltStack.
So
Should
we
uninstall NeoVim?
Yeah. Let's do it. Alright.
Okay. So now we're just gonna run and
try, apply
commands.
Right?
Yeah.
Alright. And
there we go. Yep. See where we did
the, software dot invim action first.
Actually, did not know, was a dot. I
guess if you could talk a little bit
about that. I I would have assumed a
forward slash. I haven't had to do too
much with, dependencies yet, but I need to
get better at using those.
No. I I need to get better at
documenting.
However,
yeah, so there's a couple of things that
are actually happening here, but Comtrya. The first
one being, you know, the
manifest name is the filename, except for the
special case where it's main dot yaml,
and then it uses a paired directory. This
was also stolen. I was a huge SaltStack
fan.
I used SaltStack for a decade,
and it's what I used for my own
dot files until I got fed up of
it.
SaltStack
isn't really meant to run on local host,
well, it can.
So it doesn't do a status report and
a progress report and stuff like that, things
I wanted to fix Comtrya.
So I stole some of the things I
liked,
which is the naming convention and the dependency
syntax.
So, you know, Comtrya supports dependency resolution
from
the current working directory where you run Comtrya
or from wherever it finds a Comtrya dot
YAML if you have one.
So you can always do absolute with software
dot and then,
you know, as many dot directories as you
need to get to your manifest name.
But you can also do local
dependencies, which are
dot
and then if you were doing it from
an the software, which again is lifted straight
from SaltStack. So it's supposed to be familiar
and just the syntax that I like.
The
manifest loader loads all of the manifests
and scans for dependencies that builds that DAGs
that I kinda mentioned earlier, and then they
get executed
in reverse order, making sure dependencies are always
satisfied before anything else.
You can't do
action dependencies.
Manifests always run top to bottom in a
linear serial order,
and that's gonna make asynchronous
run times in the future much easier without
the DAG again too convoluted.
Something that SALT stack allows
is every single task within any state file
can have a dependency
or reference to other ones, and then you
never actually know the execution order.
And I wanted some degree of
comprehension from just reading the manifest without going
too deep. So that's why some of these
trade offs were made. And, hopefully, it just
makes it a bit easier to work with
as as well.
We could also run Comtrya without the dash
d and without the dash m. So do
you wanna just run Comtrya apply?
Because,
you know, the dash d is the default
out of the box,
and you don't need dash m at all.
It just run everything. Oh, yeah.
Oh,
I've lied to you.
What's in this directory? Do a l s?
Just the, two folders.
Oh, that should work.
Alright. I guess dash d is required. I'm
I'm not sure when that changed. But just
to Comtrya dash d. Apply
and see if that fixes it.
Oh, you need to No. Path. Yeah.
Okay. Yep. Yeah. So that runs everything with
depends on the resolution. So
yeah.
There's a really cool PR, and we'll talk
about this at the end. I don't wanna
get into it deep now. But I I
don't think any of us are particularly happy
with the output of Comtrya. We'd love to
see that
Yeah. Made a little better. So
Yeah.
There's a
for debugging, it's not too bad, and how
we have the output has come in handy
lots of times. But
there's
it's not always,
the best, especially,
like, this portion of it. We do have
somebody who's working on progress bars.
I think we also do have some places
in Comtrya where we probably aren't tracing like
we should. Like, sometimes we have something that's
tracing as a warning when it should be
tracing as information. I've kinda slowly been going
through and clean up what I thought
what bucket it better fit in.
That's probably another
little bit of a sore with the
output of Comtrya is that we do have
some things that I don't think get traced
correctly.
Yeah. Well, come on. Let's cut some slack.
It's a 0.9
project. Oh, yeah. Well well, also, some of
it is just kinda difficult. Like like, there's
been some that I've changed where I'm like,
I kinda could go either way, but for
some reason, my gut's just telling me info
is correct or a warrant is correct.
And there and there have been a lot
of those.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's show a couple more examples.
I've got loads in my head. I don't
know if there's something you want to show,
but I can keep throwing things at you
if you want.
One thing real quick.
Probably won't necessarily be able to run an
action, but one mentioned since we were messing
with the package.install
is that
I mentioned the term earlier was
provider.
Comtrya does have this concept of, like, providers,
and it's not just in the package install
while we use it a few other places.
But the idea with the
in the context of package install is
sometimes you have a platform that can support
multiple package managers,
or
maybe
you run
Arch, but for some reason, you want to
use apps. Like, that is a possible thing
to do.
You can override the default
selection
of package manager with the provider.
Actually, really
two really good examples of why this might
be necessary.
Actually, a few.
For macOS,
there's two primary package managers that people use.
There's brew and mac ports.
Brew is what Comtrya defaults to. But if
you don't like Brew and you like Mac
ports,
which I've used, I've kinda gotten more into
Brew, but I used to use Mac ports
a lot. You can specify specifically to use
Mac ports over Brew.
As you can see, this has been new
and was actually contributed by a coworker of
mine,
support for SnapCraft. So being able to use
Snap packages. So if you're on, like, Ubuntu
or a Linux system that has Snap and
you would rather your package come from Snap
than from apps,
that's possible.
And then
package in here from the NetBSD team is
a cross platform. So you can use Package
in on Linux.
You can use on macOS. You can use
it on free BSD, NetBSD.
If you wanna use Packagen on macOS,
your Comtrya will allow you to do that.
You just have to specify the provider, and
you gotta you gotta bootstrap
Packagen on your own on macOS.
Nice. I had no idea someone had to
snap, but now the feudies inside me where
I have to go add Flatpak and make
it better. So Yeah.
That was kinda because he asked me, what
was the next thing he should work on?
Because, he's he's a coworker who wanted to
get into open source. I'm like, well,
I've got a you know, I kinda maintain
a Rust project, and I can help you.
So he did snap, and he did a
couple of other things. I could probably stick
him on flat pack.
Okay.
So
let's
let's show show off something cool, and we
can integrate it to the the providers or
we could do something slightly different. But let's
modify our NVIM manifest.
Alright.
Because I think
the conditional syntax and the variance are really
I don't think
this is nice in other tools like this.
So
let's assume right. So
I'm gonna take us on a round of
a a weird tour here, and this doesn't
make a lot of sense if you're familiar
with Comtrya. So Todd's gonna be like, why
are we doing it this way?
Right. But we have where conditions on the
manifest
and on actions. Right? So
let's add a where condition to this manifest
that says only run on Linux,
which we just do at the the top.
Where if I remember was it? You just
do
o s dot name equal equals,
I think.
But we can show people how to list
that as well. So
if you run Comtrya context
on the command line, it'll list all of
these variables that we have access to.
Oh, yeah. And I guess, while we're showing
this, something else that was added, and I
believe it's now available in version zero dot
nine dot one.
We'll give you this list, but I don't
think we ever necessarily showed you the values.
I think, actually, Stefan implemented part of this,
and I think I just surfaced it up
through a command line option maybe. I may
also be just remembering, but
should be able to do show values.
So if you're confused, you can see
what the values are.
Yeah. And we have always named dot Linux.
So Mhmm.
Just
because Stefan is watching,
can we pull up one of the examples,
which I think is absolutely ridiculous,
but so much fun at the same time?
Yeah.
It's the DNS
variables.
I
think it's under
there's no context. So it must be under
where maybe?
Wait. If they're for
No. I don't know. Search repository for
text, TXT.
Maybe Stefan don't know what it is. It's
just so
silly but fun.
Oh, that's searching. I already just did a
code search rather than a file search. Oh,
yeah. Shoot.
I don't do that too often. At the
top?
Slash?
Forward slash?
No. But you have to be able to
say dot text box. Sorry. Oh. I'm setting
up a failure now. Yeah. Just click anywhere
and then do slash and then type TXT.
Is this
yeah. I think variable include DNS. Well, that's
a code. Yeah. That's code.
But, yeah, if you just do a proper
yeah. That first one there, an examples directory.
TXT.
Yeah.
And then add TXT to the search.
Sorry. I'm I'm detracting now from anything useful,
but this is fun.
Just to type TXT and hit return.
There
you go.
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. And I can try
that. Yeah.
So that actually does a DNS text record
lookup
for his domain.
And so, like, if it's one of those
use cases where if you want to run
Comtrya in the cloud, you could actually access
the, you know, the metadata on the AWS
EC two instance or DNS text records to
do some sort of IP address resolution or
even just pass down properties, and the machines
could pick them up. And it just opened
up some really weird use cases. So we've
never pushed or explored, but I just think
it's really it's it's just good fun. So
yeah. I don't even know if his text
records still exist, but it it was definitely
fun when he did it.
Sorry. Anyway, I I took it away from
what we're actually gonna show there. So let's
jump back to our terminal.
I've seen that loads of times, and I've
and I've always wondered. I'm like,
what what's going on there?
Yeah. It's the the idea being that, you
know, when you can include remote variables, this
is like salt pillars for anyone that is
familiar with SaltStack,
and we support DNS. It could be easy
to metadata. It could be
postgres lookups. Like, you know, we can make
anything supportive,
but we just don't have the request. And
I think, again, it comes down to documentation.
Like, unless, you know, to go and find
that that piece of code or look at
that example, you wouldn't even know you could
do DNS
lookups within the variable context. So. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, also, that like, yeah. Of course, they
exist. So
And
yeah. So
I guess seeing that, if you notice, it
says Comtrya.YAML.
For people watching this, this is almost kinda
like a configuration file for Comtrya.
There has been kind of a cool change
here. Before, I believe it's always ever looked
at, like, the roots of your manifest directory.
And I think there's maybe, like, one other
place, but you could never
specify,
like, a specific like, you could have a
config file just in a random place.
Now
as a version zero dot nine dot one,
there should be a command line option that
allow you to say, hey. Use this specific
one.
Don't know if anybody will use it, but
it's there if somebody needs it for some
reason. If they have multiple different manifests, but
or, maybe multiple different directories for some reason
and but they wanna have, like, a shared
config.
Nice.
Alright. Where were we? Oh, yeah.
Where's the Linux? Let's change it to Mac
OS and then just show that it doesn't
run first and foremost. And that'll make sure
we haven't make any mistakes.
I'm showing macOS is all lowercase.
It is all lower everything gets lowercase in
the
context, I believe.
So apply. So here we see what what
partition failed.
Yeah. So now if we change this to
Linux, it should run again.
What have we got wrong on that? Oh,
I have wrapped Linux in Quartz.
Oh, yeah.
It's looking for a variable called Linux, is
probably an empty string.
And there we go.
Okay. One more change for me, please. Let's
add to say a similar where condition to
our first action. So we're saying always run
this manifest for Linux machines, but now let's
only run it on Arch.
Alright.
Where is that? .Family.
Oh,
we probably do need some documents. Is that
is that variance, I think?
Oh, yeah.
Variance.
I mean, variance and wear conditions. I mean,
I'll we'll need to get into that too,
but you can see the example at the
bottom there. Yeah. Standard wear condition without variance,
and then I'll talk about variance as well.
Alright.
So
No. You don't need variants for this example.
Where
and then was it just OS.fan?
Yeah. 0s.fam.
Or may I can't remember. We may have
to check the context.
Okay. And, I mean, that shouldn't run now,
so let's run it.
Nothing to be done reconciling
action.
Ah, yeah. We haven't spoke about the plan
stage.
You wanna talk about that?
The plan stage, if I recall correctly,
essentially, the plan stage will take a look
at the action and will determine if it
can run or not, if I recall correctly.
I'm I'm usually
too deep into the code, not too much
into the, interfaces.
Yeah. We'll pop up in the manifest, and
we can talk about it.
Yes. So
the manifest where clauses are executed before any
actions are are parsed. So that says, you
know, do we even need to understand these
actions?
And the actions themselves,
I mean, actions within Comtrya
have something called a plan, which tries to
determine if any of the steps need to
run. Actions are actually composites of atoms. I
don't know if we need to get into
that, but it's a cool subsystem for building
your own actions.
Yeah. But this work condition actually never has
to
be executed because the package is already installed,
and this action doesn't need to go any
deeper. So it just says NeoVim exists. So
we'd need to remove NeoVim again and then
run it and hopefully see that the action
is
skipped.
Sorry. I'm I'm pushing you into parts like
Comtrya. You have not explored before now. I
feel bad. Oh, it's all good. Yeah. It's
mostly just a lot of, like, the, wear
conditions and variants. I haven't dealt too much
into it. Although, I really should because
the documentation probably does need to be updated.
Or Oh, yeah. For sure. Like like, I
think there's things like the variables we don't
really have documented.
So I removed it. Nothing to be done.
Too much stuff. I mean,
did we remove the event? We did.
Yep.
I wonder if it's just because the where
condition failed, and it just says nothing to
be done. Maybe we don't actually specifically call
it the
conditional, which is an improvement. I think we
should make it. That's correct.
Mhmm.
Let's run Comtrya context to make sure that
value is what we expect, and then we
can update it so that it does run.
Let's see.
You don't need show values.
Family.
Year near future.
A family is your unit. Oh, distribution. Oh,
yeah. Distribution.
Yeah. That I wonder where we pull the
family from. So I've also done some work
on the one of our dependencies,
the OS info.
But I don't know if that comes from
OS info or not. I don't think so.
Because I tried to introduce a concept to
families to solve a problem. I can try
it, but it's been an open pull request
for, like, two years with 30 comments on
it.
Yeah. We should probably just fork factory at
some point.
Yeah. The problem I was trying to solve
there was because OS info, it also gets
used by cargo itself.
I wanted to double check the name of
that because I started talking and forgot it.
Distribution.
Okay. I wanna make sure it wasn't short
for distro.
Some of the problem is with, like
so in the package provider,
it's how we determine which package provider we
use. It's just this long match statement that
will the more distributions we add, the longer
and longer it'll be. And I was hoping
to kind of shortcut it
with kinda, like, this idea of, like, operating
system families. Right? So we know, like,
it's a pretty good heuristic to say any
Debian or Debian based distribution
has that.
Any Arch and Arch based distribution
has the ability to use
Paru or Ye or Pacman.
But that kinda came a little bit of
a debate, and it ended up not going
anywhere.
But And set it to Debian, capital d,
as we want it to run this time.
Debian.
That was good. Installed.
Alright. I'll say one more thing about that
manifest, and then you
can pick something else to show. But the
reason variance exist
is, you know, if we wanted to change
the name of this package from Debbie and
then Arch, say Arch is NVIM or whatever.
Having two actions to me felt dirty. And,
you know, that's how that's how it exists
in other systems.
And while we can use Jinja, and hopefully,
we never show anyone how to do Jinja
and Comtrya, is that I'd also don't want
that that templating approach to be how we
do it. It should be more declarative.
So the variance in taxes, okay, we have
one multiple variance of this single action
where you can have the where guard clauses,
and then you can override
any property
on the action
with the variant syntax,
which is also great. You don't need to
type it. We can just show it from
the on the docs. I think the example
there is pretty
good.
Alright.
Let's see.
The the
users ones might be pretty cool.
Yep.
Users.
Alright. So
something I believe it was new early
last year maybe
was the ability to have can try to
create users. Now granted, I do not believe
this works on Windows. So we do have
some functionality where it's
it should work on most Unix systems, but
on Windows, it probably doesn't work. I believe
we have this surrounded
with
compilation flags. But if you know you need
to set up specific users
or and groups to and you need to
add users to groups, Comtrya
has manifest actions to do that.
One caveat about this is it's not tested
necessarily on everything. So
if you come across, like, a Linux distribution
where
adding users is slightly different
or a BSD or macOS,
just drop an issue, and I can investigate
it and fix it.
Because some distros do do it a little
differently,
But
yeah. Let's see.
So let's start off by
creating a group. So do
group.add,
and we'll just call the skip the group
name of test.
So
try
You've done a table.
Good. Yeah.
Oh.
It's a universal law of people watching you
type.
No kidding.
It happens at work too. Like, whenever I'm
pair programming at work, it's like, I can
type just fine when I'm at my desk
alone. As soon as I'm pair programming and
I'm on the keyboard, it's like I can't
type anything.
Yep.
I believe when I developed this, I was
using Debian, so it should work.
That
actually go through.
What's your fail code and users?
Oh, yeah. That might be it.
It's user.
Yeah. Probably why. So you need to do
users
dot user.
There you go. Alright.
So
oh, I need to look this up. It's
been a while. You can type
ID in the group name, or you can
just cat slash Etsy slash
So there we have our test group down
there.
Let's see.
Nano
action
user dot add
the parameters for this guy.
Get my focus back.
Full name, test
user,
slash
home slash test,
username,
test,
and then go to shell
s h.
And
you should also be able to
use a dot group, add it in a
follow-up action.
Username
test
group
test.
So we've already created our group, so should
just kinda skip over that because that's already
done. Then we'll add a test user, set
its values,
and then we should be able to add
it to the user group.
Oh, and we did have a failure. Alright.
Oh, I wonder
okay.
This might be something I need to go
back to fix. I think I made
I think it has something to do maybe
with the summarize.
Well, I mean, the summarize is just saying
it doesn't know how to describe what action
it performed.
I attached a few dash v's onto that,
and we'll probably see an error message.
User mod Okay. So it's your user mod
command doesn't exist.
Oh, okay.
That makes Is user mod installed?
Because on Debian, I don't think that's a
default.
Yeah.
It's
Oh, it is. Yeah. It is.
It might Scroll up again.
Or
Yeah. I'll just run it. Yeah.
Oh, user
yeah. Debian is add user instead of user
oh, no. Invalid shell.
See, with Linux, it's weird because you get
user add or add user depending on the
distro.
Yeah. But that's actually complaining about invalid shell
SH.
I wonder if I just come here and
fully path it.
Why do you need to provide the shell
for user add?
You actually might not need to. I need
to double Oh, this is for the user
shell. Right? Not the location shell. Okay. Okay.
Gotcha.
Yeah. And this may also be something of
I I implement I think the first system
I did was
FreeBSD.
So a lot of this might have come
FreeBSD
where whenever you add a user and it
walks you through, like, its user ad script
or the options, you do have to specify
a shell.
That kinda comes back to some of the
difficulty with supporting multiple platforms is
my general philosophy is try to think of,
like, a base set of functionality that goes
across all the platforms.
Sometimes it works. Sometimes it doesn't.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So it still failed. So
it might just be, something I need to
dig deeper in. Exists.
Yeah.
You want to add a user to this
group,
So it might just be the way it's
get assembled on Debian.
Maybe the plan step doesn't
check the group properly.
Possibly.
I wonder if I take the group out.
Nope. Still fails.
User add group test exists if you want
to add this user to the group test.
Yeah. We can fix that later. Yeah.
Although, I've got a feature request for you
now based on that manifest.
Alright.
We'll pop it back over again.
Something that would be really cool. You know
how we like, we we define the user
dot group,
whereas that was a test group, and then
we define the user username. But then we
have the user group action, which actually consumes
both of those properties.
Instead of duplicating the test username with the
test group name, it'd be good if we
could reference other actions within the manifest and
pull out outputs.
That'd be a really cool feature.
Oh, yeah. It would.
There's something to get you thinking about, you
know, as you ease into 2025.
Oh, yeah.
Just as another mention because earlier, we had
talked about providers,
user users also use kinda like and groups
use the same, like, provider syntax,
and that actually may be some of the
problem we're facing here is because
I believe I originally wrote this on Debian,
but it might have been
Arch. I might have been running Arch when
I did.
But we just have one overarching Linux user
provider, which probably is not
what we should do. We should probably find
a way to better separate that because some
are user ads, some are user mod,
try to use whatever is available on the
base system, which is another thing where it
comes into the struggle of supporting multiple platforms
is
also wanna make sure whatever we use is
available on the base system on a fresh
installation because of, like, David's use case of
he refreshes a laptop.
Alright. So we've showed packages,
users,
groups,
variants,
where clauses. I mean, we're still only scratching
the surface of things Comtrya could do.
You know, you can do pulling GET repositories,
binaries from Github.
Yeah. I think maybe we could just go
over the documentation for files, and then we
could have a better chat about the future
of of Comtrya.
Yeah. I think we should also talk about
the git too. The the git integration, especially
since that has kinda changed.
We'll start with files and directories.
So,
this is actually missing some documentation that I
just discovered about a week or two ago,
and I've opened up an issue.
We do have more stuff available for directories
that is implemented. It's just not in the
documentation.
But we have these file and directory options.
We can do file copies,
download link, remove. Unarchive
is a rather newer one.
We have some of the same functionality with
directories. We can create a directory. We we
can copy. We can delete.
And we have the listing.
One
special thing, and David will correct me if
I'm wrong here.
With these file actions, you need to have,
like, a files directory
colocated
with your manifest.
I hate it so much.
But, yes, that is a current restriction
or constraint.
And the reason was is that we
Comtrya will find every TOML and YAML file
nested in any arbitrary depth of directories to
the point where if you have YAML configurations
for any other project, those couldn't be parsed
and would fail the invocation.
So instead, we block them out or wrap
them in a files directory. I would love
to see that constraint lifted.
It's just how do we do it in
a way that a Comtrya manifest can be
identified
differently from any other random configuration because we
do not have any discriminators
that say, hey. I'm a Comtrya manifest in
that YAML, which maybe we have to
admit defeat at some point and make a
breaking change. But
who knows? I I again, I'd love to
see that not be a constraint, but it
is for now. Yeah. I I see where
it's a pain for people. Me, personally, I
haven't minded it. I've actually kinda liked it
where I can separate,
like, using it at work. One of the
big things I've really used that files directory
for is
Stefan,
You know, like, I'll have, like, a Postgres
configuration
file, or I'll have a
a net plan or one of those files.
And it's like, it's just nice to be
able to say, okay. Where are those files?
Oh, they're in the files directory
with where the manifest are. For me, I
kinda do like it from an organizational aspect,
but I see where some of the pain
is. A
nice separation between what are Comtrya files and
what are not.
Yeah.
It's it's it's it's not an immediate problem
and not something I think we have to
solve
until we get more complaints. You know, I
think there's only been one or two complaints
about that directory needing to be a thing.
But
one other thing I'll call out about fails
because it's pertinent to some discussions that we've
been having recently.
With Comtrya, we do a lot of command
execution,
which we do because it's very easy to,
you know, elevate privileges.
All file actions across Windows, Mac, Linux, and
PSD are actual syscalls,
which means we can't elevate privileges, which means
eventually you're gonna wanna put something that doesn't
live in your home directory
and Comtrya can't handle that unless you run
it as root.
I mean, I don't know what the solution
is there. I know we've talked about I
suggested maybe going down the pool cat root.
You know, we could just cheat and set
UID one, the the binary, which, of course,
I would never encourage anyone to do. Yeah.
But there there I think there needs to
like, if we're gonna say Comtrya has progressed
beyond dot files to do actual system administration,
at some point, we need to I mean,
I would say the simple dump solution would
be we shell out. I mean,
that's that's kinda, like, the fallback because we
can always elevate whenever we shell out, which
we did not show, but we can also
show that too real quick.
What we mean by elevate is
here in command dot run, as an example,
we have this, like, privileged
key that you can put, and it's a
true or false. It's defaulted false. But if
you set it to true,
we'll essentially throw a sudo or do s
or run zero in front of your command
So that way we can elevate privileges
as that command runs.
The pull kit one is interesting. The only
thing I think that's kinda difficult is, like,
pull kit is not, in my understanding, is
not available in the base of macOS. So,
like, if you were to go back to
macOS and try to stand up a machine
from scratch from refresh install purely using Comtrya,
you'll probably hit issues,
which means to get around that, you would
have to bootstrap Homebrew yourself.
That's one thing we didn't mention.
Some of the package managers,
Comtrya has the logic to build a bootstrap
itself. So from from a clean system, whenever
you do a package install,
Comtrya will run a bootstrap process for Homebrew
on macOS, and it should automatically configure Homebrew
for you so you don't need to do
that yourself.
In the case of pull kit, you would
have to
you kinda lose that functionality to bootstrap Homebrew
yourself
potentially and pull pull kit because pull kit
is available in homebrew or some variant of
pull kit.
Tricky. Right? There's never an easy solution when
we start getting into these, you know, expanding
the scope use cases. But they they are
things, I think, you know, you and other
people that use Comtrya would like to see
solved. But I I don't think there's a
great answer. No. Other than running it, you
just sudo it. Just sudo Comtrya. Right? Yeah.
We just shell out.
Or we shell out. Yeah. I mean Yeah.
Maybe that is the answer. I mean, the
fails are the only time we ever use
Cisco. Maybe we should just rip it out.
Yeah. Just get rid of the atoms and
just have it really run the command dot
execute.
Yeah. Had a an underneath the hood. And,
I mean, the good thing is is, right,
for all these actions, there is an equivalent
command line program that does it. So
True. True.
And I'll make you start Go
ahead. Alright. So the file and archive, that
one is rather new.
This one should allow you to be able
to pull, like, a tar dot g z,
and we can uncompress it for you. And
I believe we can also run it as
a finalizer on file dot download. I think
it might be one of the few, like,
legitimate finalizers we have,
which something we haven't talked about initializers and
finalizers. But
but we should definitely make more use of
them.
Yeah. They were
I don't know. I don't know if it
was me getting into over engineering land, which
I am guilty of a lot. You know?
I was like, I'll try
it's engineered in a way that it's supposed
to be easy to add actions and atoms
and they're separate things and initialize some final
edges with a way to modify the execution
chain of the DAG that
we never really built too much into,
but maybe in the future. Right? I mean,
if people don't know they exist, that's okay.
It's only when you come to build actions
that those really become more important.
So Yeah. We'll see.
But what I'm hoping you know, we can
talk about get as well. What I'm hoping
that people see from all of this stuff
is that, you know, Comtrya is a pretty
powerful tool, and I'd love to see more
people helping you out and adding actions and
opening issues and stuff like that. So but
before we dive into that more, why don't
you go through the the Git stuff?
Alright.
So I guess the Git stuff needs a
little bit of history.
We used to use Git to RS and
Git sync,
but it was always a problem child. A
lot of it was because of OpenSSL.
We would have people opening up issues, like,
every few months of saying, hey. I pulled
down the project, and I can't compile, Comtrya.
Something's broken. Something's wrong. And it's like,
do you have the open SSL development dependencies
installed on your machine?
No. They don't. And,
yeah, and I've tried to solve it a
couple of different ways. But,
ultimately,
earlier this year, I came down to
it's a constant headache for us. Let's just
rip out git completely,
and there are some potential avenues.
But
at least at the time when I was
at it, it's like they're not ready yet.
The big one was another one we would
also get issues opened up for was how
come you guys aren't using anything?
You know, how come you guys aren't using
Rust TLS? Well,
OpenSSL is a transitive dependency. Like, Comtrya doesn't
directly pull it in. It's because of the
Git stuff for the most part is why
we have OpenSSL.
And
so we would mention that, and then they
would say, alright. Well, why don't you use
GitOxide or Geeks, which are really kinda two
two of the same. One is like a
library. One is the front end,
which is, for those who don't know, it's
like a reimplementation
of Git and Rust.
And I've been tracking that for close to,
like, two years. I think David has too.
It's like for two years, it was just
never fully there. Right? It's kinda like one
of those things where,
from my perspective, the GetOxite project got 85%
of the way there, but it's that last
15%
that's, like,
where the real hard work comes in.
It's like my manager says from his days
working at Microsoft. You know, it's it's
was it the first ninety percent is 10%
of your time, and that last 10 is
the 90% of your time
when it comes to software development?
Yep.
But over
this last fall,
I went ahead and gave it a shot
again with Geeks and GitOxide, and I was
able to kinda bring back some of the
Git functionality that we had. I don't think
it's complete one to one, but at least
we have something.
The functionality here, you see we have actions
where you can have an action to call
a git clone.
This one probably isn't the biggest use of
the git functionality.
The biggest one is
this may break on my machine, but I
do have a little bit of an example.
.Com/tc/double
files.
Apply.
Let me
take a look at that because this was
just an experimentation of mine.
Find something to apply.
Yeah. I love that functionality. I was sad
to see it be taken out, but I'm
glad it's back because,
you know, if you wanna run Comtrya
as a cloud config scrap on a cloud
server,
You you don't really need to do anything
except just tell it to run, and I
can pull all the manifest then, which is
nice. Yep. Point it to a GitHub registry
or GitHub repository that has it. Well, not
just the cloud, but also, I imagine, for
your personal machines. Right? Like Yep.
You get Git, and then you just point
it, and bam, you have everything.
Nice. And, yeah, it'll pull it if you
have it as a public repository.
I haven't dived too much into what we
had with GitSync, but I think GitSync handled
some stuff with credentialing.
So Handled, yeah, using credentials. It handled,
pulling branches,
revisions, tags, a whole bunch of interesting stuff.
Yeah. So we don't have that yet. I
do plan to get back there.
Right now, it's just a dumb clone on
a public repo is pretty much what you're
limited to. But at least we have it
back, and we don't have the issues with
OpenSSL.
Alright. I need to ask a question now
because it's staring me in the face, and
it's annoying me. But can you go back
to the documentation?
Alright.
You've got pre zero eight seven and then
post, but the only thing that's different is
you changed repository to repo URL.
Why was that?
To be honest, I think it was just
as I was bringing back the actions. I
it was just how I wrote it. I
could change it now. But but it was
like, oh oh, I also
kind of at least at the time when
I was writing it, yeah, it was just
something I just did at at the at
the moment. I wasn't
really looking at how the prior struct was
written.
Also, kinda want a clear differentiator between the
two.
And, also, I think one of the things
I wanted to kinda capture was,
to me, with how it was before, it
kinda seemed a little bit GitHub centric.
And I think it actually did. Like, if
you didn't provide a a full URL, it
would just automatically assume GitHub. And it's like,
I kinda want it to seem a little
bit more universal if you have, like, a
public repository on, like, Bitbucket or GitLab or
something.
And to me, I thought that that just
kinda defined it a little bit better.
Nice. And, yeah, we don't append GitHub.
So if you do this, it'll probably fail
because it won't know to default to GitHub.
So you do have to give it the
fully qualified, like, URL.
Alright. Makes sense.
Alright. I think we've covered most of the
use cases. I'm gonna pop us back to
biggie face mode, and we can talk about
what comes next.
So
Comtrya's cool.
There are lots of things with it. Make
it a little bit easier. Yep. Try to
be able to toggle to play more options.
But
why don't you tell us, like,
do you think you will be adding or
changing that and try over the next three,
nine, twelve months?
And what issues do you see people talking
about? What changes are people looking for?
Alright. So I haven't really thought far enough
out for twelve months. I guess I should
probably talk about kinda how I imagine releases
going forward first.
So in the past with Comtrya, we've kind
of always just released whenever we felt it
it it was kinda like the Linux kernel.
Right? You know, Linus Torvald is famous for,
like, version numbers don't necessarily mean anything special.
He just cuts a new release whenever he
feels it's ready. Right?
There's
no, like, strict standards. And that's kinda how
Comtrya was for a while. A lot of
that was because, you know, we would get
busy, and we'd go months without doing anything,
and then we would come back, implement a
lot of stuff.
And that can kinda present some problems where
if it doesn't look like work is getting
done,
the project can look dead even though maybe
it's not.
So with having kinda taken over more responsibility
for the project, my goal is to try
to do a release every quarter.
So I just recently, last week or the
week before, did the
zero point nine point one release, and I'm
looking for the next release to be sometime
in spring. I'm trying to line it up
with the seasons.
Reason for that is,
one, it gives me a goal. If it's
open ended, I'll just go months and months
without thinking about it. Whereas if I kinda
set a deadline,
at least I have I I set a
deadline,
for myself, then I have something to work
towards.
And right now, I'm only kinda thinking one
release ahead.
But the
big things I'm hoping to get done within
the next release is,
I have quite a few issues here, and
I've been organizing them by stones. And for
anybody who wants to contribute, you don't need
to worry about that. That's just me organizing
what I think I can get done in
a three month period or hope to get
done, and some of it'll change because I
haven't groomed it. I may have added too
much stuff.
But the big one is service management, which
has been a topic we have talked about
a lot on and off over the last
two years.
For those who aren't familiar, that'd be like
on Linux, you're a system CTL with system
d.
MacOS, I'll probably do brew because brew does
do service management,
but could do launch d directly. But I
don't see that being too
of or done too often. And then, of
course, for the BSDs,
That's probably gonna be the biggest one I
plan to do during the next release, but
we do have some cool issues that I'm
hoping we can also get to also.
There's a feature for
downloading binaries directly from GitHub that I think
could be useful.
There
was an interesting one brought up of
having Comtrya be able to kinda modify and
manage CronTab.
Oh, nice. Yeah.
That would be a pretty cool one to
do. One I do hope to do so
as we talked about providers earlier,
if you have different package install actions,
you would have to
specify that provider in each one. I would
like to do something with the configuration file
to kinda do, like, an overarching context so
that way you could have a configuration file
and say, hey. Whenever you see package install,
let's
go ahead and override it so we don't
have to do it in every single action.
Kinda like what we do with privilege
escalation,
which we could go back and talk on
that if you want to because that's kind
of interesting.
Another one that I would like I don't
know if I'll get it done this next
release, but I like to do some more
research.
It's an old issue that we've had for
a while, and we have talked about it
a little bit was adding an update flag
to package install.
And
I think a lot of that boils down
to the name is somewhat incorrect.
It's not so much update. It seemed more
like version pending.
But that's an interesting one because
this kinda goes back to
kinda like not all platforms support everything. Same
thing with, like, package providers. Right? Not every
package not every package manager necessarily has version
pending.
Yeah. I mean,
like, there's been a lot of requests like
that over the years. But in my head,
it doesn't
I could be convinced, but it doesn't make
sense because I always feel like once you've
run Comtrya,
you know, at Pacman,
you know, ports, whatever, they already then
it's their job to maintain that state going
forward. Comtrya is stateless. So it's like, why
would you not just run at upgrade? Yeah.
Yeah. And I can kinda see that too.
Or then, like, yeah,
we're using deviant on set postgres servers on
deviant.
They do offer different versions of postgres. Like,
postgres. Right? And
you do that by it's like PostgresQL
tag 15, and that's Postgres 15. But if
you want 16,
you can do tag 16. But if you
just do PostgresQL,
that'll pull 16.
There's tech 14 for version 14.
So
some package managers, you you can just control
it by
the package name functionally. So
like I said, I don't know if there'll
be any movement on that one, but something
I like to do a little bit more
research to see if there is something. Like,
I know with Homebrew having recently put Comtrya
Brew,
Brew formula and core can also build masters.
So instead of being tagged to a version,
it could also do, like, the head. K.
That might be kinda useful, especially for something
like Comtrya where three months between releases.
Right? There's stuff that may be in the
documentation
or stuff that's available in the main branch
that just isn't released yet into a formal
release.
Nice.
Alright. I mean, we're now at an hour
and a half, So I think it's about
time to wrap this up.
But being that Comtrya is such a cool
project and there is a bit of momentum
now, you know, I'd love for us to
be able to get back together in three
months and, you know, just go over the
the new features and, again, talk about what's
coming next so people can stay up to
date with things. But, you know, before
I'd just say thanks for, you know, taking
a good chunk of time out of your
day to sit here and, you know, check
and try it with me. It's been a
whole lot of fun. Uh-huh. It's no problem.
Yeah. It's been fun. I also got to
learn a couple new things.
It's always good.
I said, one one thing that's been really
good is that, yeah, while while you've been
busy, David and Stefan
still are pretty instrumental because there's parts
there's parts that I still have questions about.
Like, I've been all over the code base
now, but there's still things I don't quite
understand. And the fact that you and Stefan
are kinda always there whenever I have a
question and being able to answer it and
help point me in the right direction has
been a huge help over the past few
months, especially.
Well,
I
hope I can ship some more stuff with
you,
and have some more fun, and we'll take
it from there. But
it is the end of our session. And
do you have any final or last words
for the audience? Other than Comtrya.
Feel free to drop by, check it out,
drop an issue. I do monitor it, and
I do try to get back to people
within a day or two.
So, if you have any questions, there's also
the Rawkode
Academy chat,
and there's also the Discord,
pop in there. Feel free to
ask me any questions or make any suggestions.
Yeah. Go try Comtrya, and then let us
know where it fails you, and we will
we will fix it. Thank you.
Alright.
Until next time. We'll see you all soon.
Have a great day.
Hit subscribe so you won't miss a beat.
More livestream tutorials can't be beat. Keep coding.
Keep learning. It's the Rawkode way. We'll catch
you next time. Have an awesome day.
Have an awesome day.